Esta es una imagen que pocos imaginarían
de una ciudad como Bagdad una ciudad que
en el imaginario colectivo de todos está
en guerra y la realidad es que lo ha
estado especialmente rodeada por la
violencia durante años no solamente
desde la invasión de los americanos en
el 2003 sino que ya vivía con mucha
violencia durante la época del ex
dictador Sadam husein y es interesante
Porque muchos de los jóvenes mayores de
20 años que están esta tarde aquí nunca
en su vida se plantearon tener un
concierto al aire libre con jóvenes
reunidos especialmente mujeres y hombres
todos los días habían bombas en cada
ciudad la gente sólo podía ir a trabajar
no es como se ve Ahora nada como ahora
como niño no pude jugar a nada Solo
íbamos al colegio y regresábamos a casa
Yo solía vivir en mosul Así que fui
Testigo Del estado islámico vivimos allí
por seis meses cuando Ellos tenían el
control de musl fue muy duro pero
escapamos tuvimos suerte
los jóvenes que tienen Entre 10 y 15
años no conocieron la violencia sectaria
tampoco recuerdan a los norteamericanos
en las calles y mucho menos la presencia
de Sadam hussein cuando todavía era
dictador del país lo poco que han vivido
ha sido Durante los años de Isis cuando
tomó al menos el 40% del país para ellos
no es tan inusual encontrarse en un
lugar como este algo totalmente
diferente a lo que ven los mayores que
tal vez nunca pensaron vivir un momento
como este
pienso que todavía necesitamos más más
gente que entienda el concepto de
libertad que está bien celebrar Aunque
Todavía no es seguro para las mujeres